fighting fires from the air and the
ground it was like living through hell
says this woman who lost her home in the
coastal tourist city of vinaa
delmare we need help this woman says
Food Supplies clothes I lost
everything this tailor couple tries to
salvage what's left of a workshop
yum while these people search for a
missing cat areas near Vina delmare and
Bal pariso have been hardest hit home to
around a million people and about 120
kilometers from the capital Santiago at
least 12200 homes destroyed and 9,000
hectar burned the fires broke out during
a heat wave in central
Chile weather has made extinguishing as
many as 90 fires more challenging with
high winds low humidity and temperatures
topping
40° authorities are also investigating
whether arson played a role this is the
deadliest catastrophe since the 2010
earthquake that killed 500 people sign
and Chile's president said Sunday the
death toll will rise
significantly Crews work around the
clock to not only battle active blazes
but help the injured and find the
missing in his weekly address Pope
Francis prayed for the dead and injured
in the fires he called
devastating a state of emergency was
declared Friday night while the
president announced two days of national
morning will start Monday Abigail ban
global news Ottawa